so let's imagine joe biden wins this
election and and
somehow he takes office on january 20th
imagine
again we'll just imagine we'll see um
what's going to happen with the
republican party uh
it's interesting because there's going
to have to be some sort of civil war
right there's going to be the people who
still want to stay with the trump model
and maybe a sort of
uh you know restoration yeah
and by the way i hate to tell you this
folks but if he loses he can run in
2024. you know
no it's even worse because if he the day
he loses donald trump
jr becomes presumptive front runner for
the republicans not while daddy's still
alive
daddy will run until he's 112. but
tucker carlson you know like those are
going to be some of the top choices
okay but what is donald trump like
outside the tent pissing
in well he's he's the most he's the most
powerful voice
yeah he's the most powerful voice in the
republican party who gets beat
and goes and buys oan or gets installed
the head of oh and starts a media
network and becomes
a boys oan you know the crazy right-wing
television network
no well anyway don't don't watch it yeah
way further right than fox news come on
way further right than breitbart it
really exists
um and one of them one of their
reporters gets to go to the white house
press conferences and ask questions that
trump loves
but trump on the outside becomes the
leader of
now what it will be hashtag resistance
to
do to the joe biden democrats who will
be seen of having stolen this election
hat 40 of the country will think this
was a coup trump will say it was all
rigged
he will become the voice of leading of
keeping trumpism alive and
and liz is exactly right whether it's
don jude but i'm asking where did where
did the republicans go
he's donald trump is a big fat liar to
quote al franken
but he's right about this he's got the
support of 92 93
the republican party so the party is
donald trump's party but it's gonna
still be donald trump's party even when
he loses yes
so much absolutely trumpism has infected
that party
and it's gonna take at least a decade if
not a lifetime to exercise it you know
and and i do not see
larry hogan i don't see charlie baker
coming in and taking the reigns at that
party
i just don't it's the party of white
grievance and it will still be the party
of white grievance if donald trump's not
at the head of it anymore
and that will be still and don jr or tom
cotton yeah or somebody else like that
will become
that will be there will be some
resistance there'll be some people on
the on the moderate side whatever's left
of that
but that is a shriveled desiccated part
of the party yeah the part that
the vibrance of the party is now it is
racist
populist xenophobic white grievance
that's what the republican party is now
you